[Music]
this
is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting
from the dollar car rental studios it's
the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book
the proximity principal and host of the
ken coleman show daily
is here to answer your questions about
jobs careers money and life
and i'm here to help as well phone
numbers at triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five
so ken 30 years ago approaching
30 years ago um 1992
june so this will be 91
june uh i had just graduated high school
does that make you feel old yeah
well you're just a pup and um man i got
socks older than most
kelly as well kelly and i are the same
age yeah that's um
both of you just shut up but um so yeah
29 years ago this summer wow getting
ready to be 30 years
anniversary i wander in the back door of
a broke radio station
and convince the guy to let me work for
free
i love that because it would be fun i
told him if we were really bad he could
cut our pay in half
and uh we were bad i mean it was daryl
and his other brother daryl doing talk
radio
country fried tennessee hick uh
uh accent right have you managed to lock
those up
in a vault those early shows there's no
tapes i mean they don't know
the station was in bankruptcy that's why
he let me work for free and then they
didn't tape anything
and we didn't even have a delay if
people cussed on the air it just got
over the air
it was before janet jackson in the super
bowl so uh we didn't run delays until
after that
but uh i mean it was hey we're talking
money it's dave ramsey
wwtn can we help you this is what it
sounded like people it was uh
um there's nothing like nothing wrong
with sounding that way it just makes the
people in boston cringe
but um and they think i live in a
trailer or
a broadcast from a double wide so all
these years later about
i guess it's about 10 years ago or so
talkers magazine
we had worked our way up through the
ranks of talk radio shows
and we got to number three rush limbaugh
yeah of course number one and number one
talk radio show in america
and sean hannity uh my friend sean uh
number two
and then we were number three and
various people uh were floating around
four five six glenn beck was there for a
while
uh various people were hanging out uh in
the four five six seven slots
uh back and forth over the years but
pretty well the three of us were locked
in
yeah at the top and i kept trying to get
shawn to quit so that i could move up
and he wouldn't quit um he he likes
doing it
and um i give him a hard time about it
he gives me a hard time about it we i
like him a lot
and then of course our friend rush
passes away this year real
sad event and um
so the talkers magazine just came out
and now i'm number two yeah
congratulations yeah
not exactly the way i wanted to advance
no you know
but uh i'd rather just beat somebody you
have to just outlive them
yeah but you know but that's okay we'll
take it so we have 640 radio stations
today
we are the largest talk radio network in
america
we have more stations than sean and uh
but he has more listeners than we do and
so he is the legitimate king
long live the king shut up sean but uh
uh
yeah long live the king dave's not
competitive at all neither is hannity
hannity's just a little bit wired up
i'll just tell you well i sent him an
email giving him a hard time about
something he zips me back
so but he's a great guy and long live
the king so he's number one he's got
more listeners than we've got we've got
more stations but
he's got more premium positions uh
with listenership than i do across the
whole across the breadth of the whole
nation
of course he's a lot more well-known
because he does a fox show and a lot of
people a lot more people know who he is
than who i am
a lot more famous uh but i'm just
sitting over here at number two and
he hasn't helped as many people as you
have well
he might argue that but um he can argue
he has the right to be wrong
i get to say this about you i know you
don't like that attention but you this
this is happening
i show people how to help themselves yes
sure yeah so uh we're just excited about
this we are it's
quite an honor uh thanks to our friend
michael harrison that runs talkers
magazine he puts out the
heavy hundred every year i'm not as
heavy as i was at this time
that's an interesting adjective they
throw there i don't know where he picked
that up michael's a child of the 70s so
um for sure and uh he's a great guy too
so thank you michael and thank you
talkers and
that's awesome we appreciate doing the
rating and he catches a lot of flack for
doing these ratings because it's an
imperfect process and you're rating
a hundred people with big egos massive
[Laughter]
so everybody's pissed off a friend of
mine was in the
40s and i sent him a text last night i
said congratulations and he sent me one
back congratulations and
but yeah we're all we all uh have to
admit we open that thing up and look at
it every year and see how we're doing
uh although i already knew how i was
doing but yeah you know it's
it's a nice nice mention and a nice
thing and and kind of a sad footnote if
you will that you know i've been
sitting there at three for all these
years for probably a decade plus i'll
have to go back and look exactly how
many years but right about that it's
been
rush hannity ramsey rush hannity ramsey
and then of course russia's gone and so
uh here we are and all we did was give
people common sense advice
but it turns out common sense is a
superpower yeah
so there you go open phones here at
triple eight eight
two five five two five you guys jump in
we'll talk about your life and your
money
and you know ken that um side note on
that story is it fits in with the ken
coleman show you tell folks to get in
proximity
yeah and i went down and did that show i
i really did not have an intention
of having a radio career no just wanted
to help people i just saw it as a way i
had written financial piece it was in
the trunk of my car
and i saw it as a way to sell books i
saw it as a way to help people get out
of debt
and i thought if i get on the air and
just run my mouth and uh
and you know the interesting thing is is
the phones have been
jammed even as horrible as we were on
the air
i mean we were just country fried you
know i mean it was bad
and but people call from day one you
have not been able to get through the
phones on this show
ever ever since i turned it on it's a
great lesson there
i want you folks to catch this dave had
a
driving passion to help people who had
money problems some people that had
experienced what he had and then he
wanted to stop other people from
falling into that trap and that right
there is passion and mission
you love communicating you're a natural
teacher
you were doing in your church you were
doing it at the kitchen table then you
said well
how can i reach more people so let me go
try this little country fried radio
station
and you go on and the phones pick up why
and this is the lesson
it wasn't because you were a great radio
broadcaster
and you were still figuring out your
messaging the baby steps didn't even
exist
here's what i want people to hear but
what dave was saying is i'm willing
to help you with this problem he was
very clear on the people he wanted to
help this is where mission comes and we
talk about this on the ken coleman show
everybody wants to do work that matters
and you got to figure out who are the
people i want to help
the problem that they have that i want
to help them solve
and what's the best solution to help
them solve that and you started out not
knowing how good it was going to be
figuring out as you go but here's the
deal people said i've got that pain
i've got that problem dave can you help
me and sometimes we get so worried
about how good it's going to sound or
how good our solution is instead of
going
i know that pain exists because i've
felt it and i can help people just be
faithful just show up you never know
what god's going to do and that's what
this whole story is about
it's also uh be careful what you wish
for
that is true this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 dollars
a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today rena is in seattle
hi rina how are you hey dave hi ken how
are you
better than i deserve how can we help
thanks for taking my call okay so
my dad passed away who are you exactly
two years ago and
he left us with the opposite of a legacy
he left us with a
mess um no will um nothing whatsoever in
regards to bank accounts any of that
but um so he spent majority of his life
living in another country in iran
and my mom just recently went over there
to kind of try to finalize things
and she called me and asked if she could
send
money over and deposit it into
individual cups like my good savings
account
so because she's trying to avoid any
sort of penalties or
taxes and i'm serious and i don't want
to end up getting in trouble
or penalized for that do you know how
about any of that or you explain to me
how any of that would work
i have no idea about iran um
i can tell you that inherited money in
the united states
is not taxable
okay so if it's sent over from another
country you don't know
yeah why does she just not send it to
her account
i think she's worried that if she sends
all of it to her account that she's
going to
have to pay heavy taxes so she's doing
well
she needs to get some information and
get some knowledge because she's not
going to pay any taxes
and if she gives the money away she
might have gift taxes
she needs some money though he left her
with absolutely nothing so i worry about
okay
how much money is involved i am thinking
anywhere between 50 100 000. i don't
think it's going to be more than that
but i
worry then when she gets too she's gonna
then want me to transfer all of that
money or with that to give it to her
and then i'm on the line again she does
not need to send it to your kids or you
she needs to send it and put it in her
own account
there are no tax implications in the
united states for doing that
now there might be something to do with
iran i have no idea what happens over
there
um yeah but the uh uh
and you know to be super sure she would
just contact an estate
attorney here in the states that does
wills and does probate
and he can give her some instruction or
she can give her some instruction
on how to do this properly but the
common sense aspect of it is simply
send the money it's your money and
you're transferring your money
from iran to the united states there's
absolutely no implication of that at all
yeah okay were they they were married
right
yeah here's the thing they were married
and you were on
the divorce in the u.s
so how is she getting possession of this
money because she's married in iran
yeah she stayed married in iran because
she knew
that he was never going to do a will or
anything like that he was in denial that
he was even going to die even though he
had cancer for alderman
given that this is not her husband in
the united states
um then this is uh like me
taking the money from his name and put
it into my name
so she needs to contact a tax attorney
and or
a an estate planning attorney but she
does not need to send it to your kids
that's dumb butt she's going to make a
mess your your instinct was right
she's going to make a mess and she's
acting like she knows what she's doing
and she has no idea what she's doing
so just get an attorney spend 500 bucks
on it
get a little bit of advice on how to
properly do this
because it's very complicated this is an
ex-wife
by united states law and i don't know
what the divorce decree says
i don't i don't know that she has any
rights to this money
i have no idea i because i don't know if
the
marriage in iran gives her rights to it
legally in the united states so
that's a that's squirrelier than crud so
um
no you do not want it going into your
kid's name because
she might technically be accused of
stealing it at some point
oh boy i don't know who would accuse her
of that who's alive that would care
but maybe his brother still lives in
iran i don't know
so uh there's no will i don't know how
she's getting access to the money i
guess because she's a wife there i got
lee it's complicated
now she needs legal advice and you do
not put this in your kid's name your
instinct is correct
that could be a mess yeah absolutely
this is why lawyers exist oh god
[Laughter]
as much as you hate to acknowledge that
you know it's it's it this is absolutely
straightforward here that you've got to
get this figured out before anything
gets transferred
because iranian law oh boy yeah well
yeah and you got to get out of there
uh charlie's in cleveland hey charlie
how are ya
thank you for what you do and congrats
on your second largest talk show
thank you for reading yeah so my
question is
uh i have some large life events coming
up
my wife is turning 50 and next year
we're having our 25-year wedding
anniversary
yay and yeah right it's awesome
so uh i was calling to see if
the amount of money i was looking to
spend was out of line in your opinion
um so for her birthday i was looking to
spend
uh five grand on a gift and
for our anniversary i was looking at
taking like maybe a ten thousand dollar
trip
do you have the money
so that's an easy question do you have
the money
yes okay you have the money so are you
in debt
uh i owe about 85 on my house
that's all okay and what's your
household income
uh it's about 200.
so why do you need my permission to
spend five grand
uh we're pretty frugal and and we do
every dollar like
we say like we budget every dollar
literally
uh three hundred dollars for the salt
for my water bill
we budgeted it good good i mean we do
too we have a detailed
we're very intentional with our money
but we have the money to go on a ten
thousand dollar trip and so do you
we haven't like set a budget for any of
that so i would take it from somewhere
else in my
on hand cash yeah which i suspect
listening to you you're such a tight
wide you've got a lot of on-hand cash
it's all relative sir yeah
okay how much on hand cash do you have
so i probably have 50 for an emergency
fund
i probably got 25 for the next car we
buy
uh we probably have 25 for
an investment opportunity that is going
to come our way sometime in the future
and we probably have a little more cash
lying around here
let me tell you i just found your
investment opportunity yeah that's why i
was your
wife yep i would invest in the two of
the biggest dates in her life her 50th
and her 25th anniversary dude stop
thinking that's that's right you're
overthinking this you've done a really
good job with money
here's the thing you got to remember
this charlie there's only three things
you can do with money and you have to do
all three
you can be generous with it you can
invest it
and you can enjoy it and you have to do
all three to have a good life most
people
only enjoy it they're broke some people
only save it
that's you so you need to also
have fun and enjoy some of the money
and to take fifteen thousand out of that
future investment fund and do this
uh if i were in your shoes if ken were
in your shoes
stacy and sharon would demand
this our greatest investment and the roi
is it's just priceless
you're talking about that well i think
we're deeply in debt and we're still
trying to pay our way out that's what it
really
is yes the debt we will never pay off is
that we will never convince those people
to marry us we will never dig out of
this hole that is true we married so far
up that we're always climbing yeah he
needs to gamify this dave he needs to
turn this into a game where he can
rework his budget the guy loves his
budget he's a good dude he's disciplined
rework that budget to reach these
financial so you got the five and then
you've got a year and a half
good gracious two hundred thousand
enjoying grant enjoy this
so the interesting thing is what you
said was very true it is relative
yeah and this is a very small amount of
money out of the what you have saved and
out of what you make
if you make twenty thousand dollars a
year and you're forty thousand dollars
in debt
the answer is no you don't need to spend
that kind of money
on luxury items birthday gifts
and that kind of thing but sir you have
done a very good job enjoy your money
that's one of the things it's good for
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
armando and megan are with us hey guys
how are you
good how are you better than we deserve
where do you all live
portland oregon oh wow bit of a hall to
nashville
yeah so uh how much debt have you guys
paid off we paid off
four thousand dollars in uh six months
good for you and how long
i'm sorry what was your range of income
during that six months uh 153
pretty steady okay what do you guys do
for a living i'm in law enforcement
i work in healthcare admin you're in law
enforcement in portland oregon well
we're relatively i'm working for you
yeah that was the suburb
yeah yeah we're a little ways we're like
an hour oh okay in the area of portland
okay i feel better for you already
yeah i'm worried about you brother
that's a rough call right there man
oh wow fifty four thousand dollars what
kind of debt
it was all me um it was my student loans
my car and two credit cards
okay so how long y'all been married yeah
uh we got married in august
oh okay so first order of business clean
up the mess yes
yes got it okay so actually i uh so i
started this journey in 20
at the end of 2015 when i was single and
still had yet to meet megan
i paid off uh close to sixty thousand
dollars
and uh i had my emergency fund all
built up when i met megan she heard
about dave ramsey that's for sure
wow when i met her it was funny i i feel
it was funny just listening to your
entry music
when i first met him i was like man what
is this and i was listening to it here
and i was like oh yeah this is the song
i like it yeah you could be walking
through home depot and here's jerry
rafferty and it's all about dave ramsey
that's wild okay so tell me the story
you guys are dating how long
before armando starts
not being romantic and talking about
money uh
we i think on our third date he played
your podcast on our way to dinner i was
like oh this is lovely
that's next level you're a real casanova
dude
and then um our life just kind of
unfolded from there and we had to move
states
and he proposed to me right before cove
it happened so that was fun so oh yeah
our wedding planning uh was fluctuating
pivot pivot exactly and then we
decided actually to elope and kind of
set herself up for a
a better future going forward and that's
fine saving all that money yeah so
that's fun so okay so the third day you
get the podcast
oh that's just gross i'm so sorry
i didn't do it but i'm so sorry uh so uh
uh you know that you all laughing aside
how how long in this discussion was it
before megan before you start going
okay this kind of comes with the package
with armando i'm gonna have to
work on this about the third date
yeah same time yeah we had not even
before dinner
so even with our elopement we came home
from
getting married where our family lives
in washington and it was we were in the
door maybe an hour and he's like okay
let's start clicking it in let's start
making payments i was like okay well
happy honeymoon
wow it was great though it was i mean we
paid it off in six months and it's
amazing so
armando had you built up some cash to
throw at it i did we i had 20 000 in
emergency fund and so we threw 19
at it it was just followed the baby
steps exactly yeah and then i had some
um in an educational ira that we moved
to a 529
it was just a matter really for me was
um
understanding my finances and where they
were at and why in the world was i
having that ten thousand dollars just
sit in there when i was having the debt
over here it was you know
a pound of feathers panned out bricks so
it was just a matter of
uh he had taught financial peace
university too
so he was a really good teacher and
teaching me how all this works
okay i would say thorough yeah yeah so
what was the saying again i haven't
heard that in years pound of
what is pound a pound of feathers or a
pound of bricks how do you
where'd you grow up uh well northern
washington right below the border oh
okay yeah okay
so interesting so armando i gotta ask
you this so you shared with us that you
before meeting your wife paid off 60.
now you got 54. i love that you just
emptied that emergency fund because i
know that's painful
yeah i mean to get that to 20 and then
cut a check for 19. well he got her out
of the deal well that's true
but still i i really want to hear what
was it like to go through it a second
time what did you learn was there
anything different was it easier
faster and emotionally easier it was but
the difference was
seeing seeing the money come from the
savings account
and and just being emptied out it just
gave me a
more sense of urgency to get back there
because i knew what it felt like
yeah to have that yeah i'm doing some
writing on millionaires right now and
the old saying is the second million
is easier oh and after i went broke
after
having a million getting the second
million was easier because i knew i
could do it right yeah and you knew you
could do it so that's why i said that
yeah you know absolutely you've already
i've already killed a bear i've already
killed a lion
this this giant is nothing yeah you know
i already that's what david said right
so i know i can do this
and uh yeah so you knew you could do it
and it hurt but it was a short-term
thing because you knew you'd be done
fast
yeah he had a fire underneath yeah
that's for sure that's perfect
you guys are amazing okay so tell people
uh financial peace
teacher coordinator and professional
debt reducer yes 60 000 and then 54
000 both of you what are the keys that
people need to know if they want to get
out of debt
i would say the budget i mean being
single the first time
it was just me you know making the
decisions um
being accountable to myself but when i'm
when i got married with megan it was
just you know communication
for me um trying to explain why i'm
doing what i wanted to do
instead of just doing it and not not
communicating it we had a lot of
conversations
like no no that really doesn't make
sense and he's like no it does just look
i'm like well how about this way and
he's like no
it's this way this is the way i'm like
okay this is the path
okay i get it very patient
yeah but also resolute yes a lot for me
dave was i
heard this mentioned previously on your
show by somebody and it was a lot of um
i needed to slow down
i'm such a planner i'm reading rachel's
book right now and she talks about a
section of like
planning weekend trips out to the coast
and this and that and i was a matter of
like
i need to stop doing that because it's
not just a weekend trip it's 250
500 and we knew it was going to be
temporary so now
uh you know paws on life kind of a
little bit but now we got to be here on
a week-long vacation
there you go nashville and whatever yeah
yeah nicely our honeymoon i guess
oh there we go yeah cause he
he's got some um he's got some making up
to do on that i'm just saying
yeah came home and sat down at the
computer and started pecking away yeah
yeah
yeah that's just great wow guys i'm so
proud of you you're amazing what a great
couple
how's it feel feels great and really
great just
expecting expecting our first right now
oh
fun it's nice to know uh
once she gets here that we really have
financial peace it's it's great yeah you
ever go back into it
absolutely not never no not any reason
to
yeah you make really good money you got
a baby on the way
life is good i'm so proud of y'all what
a great deal you guys are rock stars
thank you you're such heroes
that's so fun we've got a copy of uh
legacy journey
because that's uh that's what you've
done you've changed your legacy
and uh i want you to read through that
and and we'll give you another copy of
the total money makeover for you to give
away
thank you and uh pay it forward to
somebody thank you for teaching the
class
we appreciate that and uh we we honored
that you guys came down here and shared
part of your uh part of your honeymoon
with us
absolutely too fun
all right armando and megan from the
portland oregon
area 54 000 paid off in six months
making a hundred and fifty three
thousand count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three two one we're different
[Applause]
that is fun wow love
that that's a power couple right there
yeah they were on uh
they were on key as well i don't know if
they planned that then the tears
from megan right after that moment of
the scream that's what i love about
watching and hearing these screams
they cross the finish line emotionally
they've already done the hard work now
it's the celebration good for them
touchdown baby yeah so good i love it
very cool this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality host of
the ken coleman show is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five a bunch of you have checked
taxes off the list for this year
but tax season is still going if your
state
got an extended deadline if you want to
get them done on time
which of course you do you've got a
couple options either online
yourself or by paying a pro we've been
thrilled and thousands
of users have too with our ramsey smart
tax
online filing tool this year it is
the best choice out there if you've got
simpler taxes
yes if you need simple if you have i
said if you need simple taxes
but that doesn't mean it's simple
software uh our software can handle
whatever you throw at it
you can do all the deductions all the
standards ones everything
write in ramsey smart tax if you want a
refund let me remind you refunds are a
assigned you overpaid
uh you need to get the refund but then
you need to reset
up everything and don't charge don't let
somebody charge you some asinine
processing fee like these other guys
it's easy it's online it's very
inexpensive and we're not going to do
anything else except i'll do your taxes
ramsey smart tax text tax to 33
789 tax two three three
seven eight nine travis is in virginia
beach hi travis how are you
hello sir how are you doing better than
i deserve what's up
so um i was wondering i'm 20 years old
currently uh baby step three i have
about 40 000
across all my savings accounts and i'm
just wondering on
what would be a good time to move out
and whether i should buy a rent
um i'm currently working two jobs and uh
running
a business myself and just a lot going
on right now
trying to decide what i should do sure
what do you make
uh last year i netted about 45-50
right around there good for you what do
you do
so i sell clothing as my business and i
work in a restaurant and i work in a
screen printing place as well
how many hours a week are you working so
i work
double shifts when i do work uh two
times a week and then i run my business
my business i'm very busy during that i
ship
i sell clothing so i ship you know
internationally
nationally going around buying stuff and
selling it so
yeah it's a lot going on you don't even
know how many hours you work you're
busting it aren't you
yes sir i would agree and your question
is
should you move out you mean move out of
your parents house somebody else's house
what are we asking
yes sir my parents house yeah i was
asking whether i should buy a rent i
have a
i have a good chunk in savings as well
i'd rent for a little while yep
right you're 20 i agree there's a lot
going to happen in the next three years
in your life
[Music]
a lot of change is coming in the next
three to five years of your life and
and and uh you know one thing it's okay
to buy if you want to buy but i would
rent for a little while
and if you buy in a year and uh then two
years later you'll meet you meet the
special girl you will discover you
bought the wrong house
hey that's that's as much truth as
you'll ever hear travis i promise you
right now
so and then you'll have to move again so
it's okay it's all right
if you want to buy but here's the thing
sometimes there's so much pressure in
our culture to to not throw money away
on rent to own
that we buy at a time maybe we shouldn't
renting is okay for short periods of
time where there's patience
involved and what your first step out of
the nest can be is just something very
simple
and you just pay the rent if something
breaks you call the landlord they have
to fix it you're not in the repair
business you're not in the
yard cutting business you're not in any
of these things you just live there
and keep working and piling up money and
you know in a year or two
if you want to buy something you're
going to have a really big pile of money
by then aren't you
um yeah my biggest concern was a
lot i sell clothes so i store everything
in my house
and just uh having this having the
storage
like leaving at home it would be a drive
just to ship stuff out
and like renting i couldn't i couldn't
run an apartment i'll have to run a
house
so so i was just you live in a house now
don't you yeah
it's just and inflating everything is
just a big concern
oh i'm not worried about inflation for
two years
right you're just getting started in
your career i'm not even worried about
inflation with a guy hustles like you
hustle
i worry a lot more about lazy people
than i do inflation
yeah oh that's very true yeah you're
going to be all right man you're going
to be just fine
go if you want to rent a little house go
rent your little house i don't care you
don't have to run an apartment
yeah and you know have to have three
bedroom house and fill up the other two
bedrooms with your inventory
you're making bank on this what are you
doing buying used clothes and reselling
them
yes sir like ebay yeah ebay
different sites grilled is one yeah i
talked to a guy the other day that had
made thirty five thousand dollars last
year doing that
hold on a second buying oh you buy a
pair
you know buy something for a quarter at
a garage sale put on ebay for three
dollars
thrift stores man i'm telling you travis
i got some clothes i need to sell you
buddy
no he buys his cheap son he sells i get
it dave
i was sitting here you're gonna get four
dollars out of this transaction all day
right
now i like this selling clothes
yeah no selling it's good you want him
to sell him for you you don't want him
to buy him from him yeah i thought
he buys he buys for nothing i get it i
get how he's doing it
he heard him say thrift stores he's
going in to find a dud man
you know thrift stores in wealthy areas
would you run for congress and take over
the world son
oh please no don't dave he'll go to
congress and it'll ruin him oh well
no i'm speaking maybe he could ruin
congress
yeah i know i'm cynical i know me too
the air up there in dc is different
it's foul james is in sydney australia
no way what's up
james hello how are you thank you
man i love your town we got to go there
in february last year but right before
covet hit
and we had a blast i love sydney
i'm glad you liked it um yeah
how can we help yeah so um
i have been saving up for 16 months till
end of the last year
which is about 35 000 australian dollars
um and this money i've been sending them
to my parents account so i'm not tempted
to spend it so
and i think it was a wise choice um i
would have definitely spent it
um and and i have been thinking
of my student depth on top of this as
well
uh but all of a sudden i was struck with
the news that
all of my saving was invested on a
tesla stock um by my father
allegedly this will be given back in
four years
from him um then she predicts it will be
quadrupled
by
[Music]
okay and and and your dad just decided
he was going to take your money
and put it in tesla stock to help you
out yeah
yep okay and so he he thinks he's making
money apparently so
which i don't i wouldn't deny it given
that if he just gets it out now
he'll be about by the end of today
by the end of today he needs to get it
out
and send it to you you're 29 freaking
years old you need to be a big boy and
not spend your own money
and you need to be a big boy and your
daddy doesn't do your investing for you
i mean i didn't even ask for it so he
literally
he literally owes me thirty five
thousand dollars
sorry you already asked for it
i he literally owes me 35 000 and
even if i ask for it he'll be like nah
he'll he you will give it back
four times although if it could ripples
no i want my money right now i didn't
send it to you too
dad i didn't send it to you to invest in
tesla i need you to cash the tesla stock
and i need you to send me my 35 000
right now
well actually my student debt is around
uh twenty nine thousand dollars okay
directly it's wiser
to actually just have that and i don't
know maybe i'll get about six thousand
dollars but
um do you owe your dad on the 29 000
is your dad tied up in your student debt
in any way
i'm sorry no i mean student debt is my
debt no so
it's not any of his concern
well i'm also paying that on top of it
anyway
i got that but you you when i told you
gave you a very direct
thing to do your answer was you started
talking about something else
[Music]
no no no what i mean is i know what you
mean you don't want to deal with your
dad is what you mean
absolutely right dude you need to throw
your shoulders back get on the phone
with your father this afternoon he's
misbehaving
he needs to cash in your freaking tesla
stock and send you your money
and then you as a man can make decisions
about what you
want to do with your money yes i would
suggest you pay off your student loan
debt but that's a separate equation you
need to get your money back
today
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsey show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone
browse by topic or even sync clips to
your friends
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host ken coleman ramsey
personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today
we're going to talk about your life and
your money ken on the ken coleman show
75 radio stations sirius xm radio
big time podcast and youtube channel
talks about your job
your career finding work that matters
knowing what you're passionate about and
that you're good at and figuring out a
way to put all that together to make a
really fun good life we're going to talk
to you about that today
as well as take your questions about
your life and your money
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
speaking of jobs ken anton is on in los
angeles with a job question
hi gentlemen how's it going thank you so
much for taking my call
sure what's up all right so i have a bit
of a
i guess a good problem to have with some
options so
just wanted to get your input and i'm so
excited that camera's done today as well
um so long story short i've been with my
company for about
four years now um
last year at the end of the year i
decided that this year i was going to
start looking for a new job
mainly due to reasons of lack of
development
uh it feels a little scale um anytime i
would ask for a little bit more work or
something to do it's just kind of like
yeah well we'll see what we could do but
uh management's not really interested in
training or developing a career uh for
anybody so
i was like okay i appreciate the work i
do and
i'll just see what else is out there
about a month and a half ago i got a new
offer from
another company which i accepted it came
with about seventeen thousand dollars of
a raise and the title raised as well so
very excited
um when i went to give my two weeks i
spoke to my
cfo at my current job and he
essentially said that he would match my
salary he would put me on a plan
to have a promotion within 12 months and
he would make sure to uh
mentor me and uh help me grow so that
kind of
helped me make it then i decided to stay
so it helped me make a decision to stay
uh here's the problem nothing got put in
writing
so i contacted the new job and i turned
down that offer
nothing at my old job got put in writing
so when the raises came around
i only out of the 17 000 that he agreed
to match
only about nine came as a race and the
other 8 000 came
as a one-time bonus uh that got
deposited into my account which is
great for the cash uh but he got super
taxed
and you know i want to talk to him about
it and he basically told me that that's
the best he could do
uh because if he actually put the whole
17 000 raised
salary i got it i got it the guy
the guy's a jerk he didn't keep his
words so what's your question
so my question is you know they paid me
out the the one-time bonus right
and i i
is it okay for me to start looking for
yes
i feel i feel a little this is the
danger in what they did to themselves
yeah and it's also the day not only did
they lie and not keep their word
they gave you all the money up front
well this was stupid yeah
and anton you knew you saw
you saw this you saw that there was no
development they weren't serious about
pouring into you that's a sign of a
great culture a company that develops
their existing people
and promotes them if those people
receive the development
and do a really good job and you saw the
handwriting on the wall
and yet you got talked back into doing
it it doesn't matter we're not
i'm not trying to knock on you but i
want you to learn from this so yes you
start looking
i'd call the other company and see if
there's still an opportunity probably
not but i certainly would start there
and i would i would i would look
and i would i would hold fast to the
lesson that you've just learned yeah and
your cfo's getting ready to learn a new
lesson yeah
he just signed he just gave you a
signing bonus for the new company
right right so what happens when you
screw people
yeah i just uh i just tell them like
it's unethical for me too you know what
i mean no
no let me know unethical was him not you
yeah he lied he lied
period end of story unless you changed
your story
is what you told us what really happened
yes sir
okay then he lied right
yeah yeah i think he just uh put his
clothes in his mouth and then when he
went to do it dude
yeah that's a form of lying yeah dave i
see this a lot this is this is
this is poor management and it's
manipulation a lot of managers and
leaders
i wouldn't even call them true leaders
they're so weak and they manipulate
people
and this was a scarcity move he was like
okay hey i'll tell you what if you stay
i'll do this and he didn't value anton
he didn't
have a principal involved in the
decision it was right the work wouldn't
go away
that's it i got to solve a problem i'm
going to manipulate somebody well and he
didn't have approval and so when he went
back to
he's a cfo he ought to get his own time
i was going to say does he need approval
yeah this is just bogus so we're going
to figure this out all we got to figure
out is anton
you don't want to be there yeah and uh
if you get a job really quick that eight
thousand dollars that they put in your
account extra is a bonus
and that's what it costs them for not
keeping their word no there's nothing
unethical about what you're doing at all
the lack of ethics was on the other side
of the equation yeah and be encouraged
don't get discouraged here you found
something before you'll find other
things
and now just walk forward so don't get
down on this one year from today
don't be working there no yeah
no out out
[Laughter]
so um
you know how do you keep good people
well number one you develop them you see
people want to
track to become
more to move up and you give them
training to move up that track oh
and you keep your word yes
why is this hard yeah do what you say
you're gonna do
yeah it's that's why there's no
competition
yeah because most people won't work hard
and tell the truth
you can beat most people by just working
hard and telling the truth yeah
most people can't even do that yeah and
so that's why there's no real
competition out there
so yeah and anton hit the road
you know dave there's also a leadership
lesson here for people who listen to
show that lead people
don't make leadership so daggum
complicated
again same advice don't lie to people
and if you just
if you give them a ladder show them a
ladder where they can grow with you
and then develop them so they can do it
as dave just said
recognize them reward them and keep them
in a place where they're doing really
really good work and they enjoy it they
will stay with you
for a very very long time
but don't over complicate this don't try
to manipulate people by the way dave we
know this from data
people don't leave companies they leave
leaders
they leave their manager that's exactly
right they get tired of that guy
that gal yeah and the being jerked
around
being kept in the dark not being told
what's going on
not being given anything to do that that
you can actually measure the traction on
uh this is just not that hard no
entree leadership we teach this stuff
all the time yeah go dive into that
yeah it's it's the whole thing there ken
coleman is my co-host today
this is common sense for your life
common sense for your dollars and cents
it's the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Music]
if you're in debt it can feel like
you're constantly at war
with all those freaking bills and
sometimes feels like the bills are
winning
you might wonder if you're ever going to
get a head well listen
does not have to be like this you can
pay off all the debt and when you do
you'll finally move forward you'll build
the kind of life you want with your
money and we'll show you how
we'll show you in ramsey plus with this
membership you'll learn how to take
control of your money and ditch
your debt for good plus you get all the
tools you need to make it happen
you can get ahead ramsey plus includes
financial peace university
every dollar premium which ties to your
bank community
coaching all kinds of things there to
walk with you help you
make sure you do the stuff you hear us
talk about here every day on the air
text the word trial to 33
789 for a free trial of ramsey plus it's
a free trial of ramsey plus
text trial two three three seven
eight nine jay is with us in tampa hi
jay welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave hey ken i hope you're both
having a great day thank you so much for
taking my call
our pleasure how can we help so my
question for you guys is sort of a
two-parter
first i have an an old employer
sponsored ira that was transferred to a
trust company
i'd like to move that money but i don't
know if i should move it to my new
employer's
sponsored 403b or if i should open a
roth
ira because i don't have one yet move
the money there
and um kind of see you know kind of
take any penalties or anything that may
come along with that there's no
penalties and i would roll it to a
traditional ira not a roth
in good mutual funds how much money is
in the account
uh it's not a lot it's like 1500. okay
just click smart vester at daveramseyra
ramseysolutions.com
and find a smartvestor pro in your area
they can help you with the paperwork and
opening up
an ira and you just roll it to that
someday later when you're out of debt
and you have some extra money
then you would just use that to
convert it from a traditional to a roth
because that makes the taxes come
due there is no penalties on what we're
talking about but
here folks when you leave your job you
always
take your retirement with you if you can
if you've got a 401k you can't
if you got a employee sponsored thing
with lump sum you can't
and you always roll it to a traditional
ira
where there's no taxes in good mutual
funds that way you have
better investment options and you have
more control always take your retirement
with you and never put it there's no
reason to put it into the new employer
none whatsoever michael is in alaska
hey michael welcome to the ramsay show
thank you it's pleasure to be talking to
you you too what's up
hey so i just got a quick question i got
a little bit of consumer debt
and i own a home so i got a little bit
of equity
um what are your thoughts on possibly
taking out
a heloc or equity loan to
pay off that consumer debt bring down
the apr
and stuff like that and then just throw
that
equity loan into my uh
debt snowball i wouldn't
okay you want to know why why
because you're going to feel like you
did something and you didn't do anything
all you did was remove it now listen all
you did was move it
interest rate's not your problem lack of
a budget lack of focus lack of attacking
this is your problem
you get fired up and pissed off about
being in debt
okay and get after your debt list it
smallest to largest pay minimum payments
on everything but the little one
and get after it because here the
problem when people move
debt around they use words like pay it
off
you didn't pay it off you moved it
and two percent savings on the interest
rate is not your issue
your issue is getting focused getting on
a budget living on beans and rice
selling so much stuff the kids think
they're next get fired up and wired up
baby
that's what does it that's what moves
the needle
can we there's so much of what you teach
about
jobs and what we teach here that is
about action
it's um motive
which leads to motivation yes personal
finance is 80
behavior it's only 20 head knowledge
there's so much about
a job or choosing a career stepping into
something
that is about um you know
don't try to trick it to don't try to
trick your way past the hard work
there's no shortcut to any place that's
worth going beverly seals used to say
he's absolutely right and so why are you
going after it you've got to remind
yourself on the journey why
am i doing this i get that it takes time
you know if you walked out on the street
today with a camera and a microphone and
you asked people
are you willing to do whatever it takes
to get where you want to go whether it
be career in your money most people look
at you and instantly say
absolutely but if i followed up and i
said
well but i think they mean that but then
here's the follow-up question if i said
are you willing to wait as long as it
takes
oh that's exactly what happens they
literally can respond that way here's
why
there's something about the human
condition we want everything now that's
what this journey is all about it's what
dave talks about all the time it is
it is the budget helps you control the
behavior issued where you go hey
this is a long slog it's going to take
time and so
you have to whether it's in your career
and doing work that you deeply want to
do because you
know you were put on this planet to do
it uh or it's paying off debt
uh and saving money so that you can live
like no one else all of this
is the same exact conversation you want
to live like no one else you want to
work like no one else
it's going to take time and you better
have the big picture in mind
and know that this is a climb but it is
going to be worth it when i get there
there's no
shortcut there is not a shortcut a
generation ago
there was one of the world's best
golfers was a guy named gary player yes
and the story's been told about him over
and over and over again through the
years that
he was warming up at a tournament on the
driving range
and he's you know pulling back that
driver and sailing that ball out there
300 360 350 yards whatever
just popping that drive straight as a
string
and this guy walks up behind me goes i
would give anything to get a golf ball
like that
mhm and i think i think he caught him at
the wrong moment because he turned
around and said no you wouldn't yeah
it's a fantastic story no you wouldn't
yeah you would not stand out here in the
heat
and hit 2 000 golf balls hit golf balls
so long that you get blisters
hit golf balls so long that the blisters
bus hit but golf ball so long that you
can't hold the golf club anymore from
the busted blisters you tape up your
hands and you hit another thousand balls
you wouldn't do that yeah that's right
you wouldn't do anything
to hit a golf ball like that to which
the poor guy just said i'm sorry i asked
him but
you know but just you know but yeah
that's the thing you know i i would do
no you wouldn't you got you got to be
willing to do it and and so
that's the thing and i'm not picking on
michael here that's not the issue
but the issue is there's a thing about
uh action
and paying the price live like no one
else so that later you can live like no
one else
that supersedes a little bit of interest
saved by moving it to a healer so true
88 of the people that move their debt
over for debt consolidation
go further into that don't get out of
that yeah nine out of ten times
yeah it's interesting they don't change
their habits and put them in there in
the first place that's right they feel
like they did something
and that's dangerous to feel like you
did something when you did nothing
yeah you know there's a theme here we're
talking about folks that dave just
brought up
you got to be passionate about getting
out of debt that gazelle intensity where
does that come from
about the next job you got to be
passionate about doing work that you
were created to do to help people
so what's funny is you do a word
exercise and there's a german word
and there's also a greek word the root
word of passion means to suffer
now here's the deal when it's rice and
beans beans and rice
gazelle intensity working three or four
jobs the last couple times i've been on
the show we've had
single moms back-to-back shows who paid
off an enormous amount of debt
with multiple kids doing everything that
is suffering
to suffer that means these people know
what the word passion folks we gotta get
this isn't like some romantic
motivational poster word
this is i am willing to suffer
to go through pain and withhold pleasure
that's what that means in order to get
an outcome that i desire
greatly whether it's starting a business
inventing a product or service
getting out of debt losing weight
changing your relationships your
marriage
i'm going to tell you something passion
you got to be willing to suffer for that
outcome
there you go this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage
sam and natalie are with us hey guys how
are you
we're good how are you very good where
do you guys live
we live in minnesota oh wow what part
just south of minneapolis
okay fun good to have you guys welcome
and
how much debt have you paid off dave we
uh paid off 320k
320k and how long did this take
58 months okay cool good for you
and your range of income during that
time
we went from about 115 last year we did
205 and we'll probably hit two and a
quarter this year good for you what do
you guys do for a living
i'm an operations manager and and i'm a
stay-at-home mom to these four amazing
kids that we have here with us i love it
so i'm guessing with 58 months and 320
000 did you guys pay off your house
we sure did
[Applause]
i love it good for you guys and it took
you five years huh
yeah wow amazing how old are you two
i'm 39 i'm 36. all right and what's this
house worth
uh this crazy market they got it about
475
[Laughter]
and it's all yours yeah that's how does
it feel to not have a payment in a
stinking world man that's amazing
it's it's still sinking in to be honest
their heads around it yep
pretty amazing well tell me the story
what in the world happened here
well um i've always been kind of money
driven you know kind of money focused
but i was out in denver um and i was
buzzing around the am radio
and i heard the southern guy come on the
radio and he was talking all about money
and talking interviewing people about
money and it was
i was glued i was hooked and anyway i
just turned it off i parked the car and
that was it and uh
i was out there again another trip a
couple months later and
i i found you again on the radio and
i was leaving denver and before i did
that
i i pulled over and i was like this
guy's got to have a podcast or something
so
sure enough i found your podcast
downloaded it and then i binged it from
denver to minneapolis
no stopping oh you drove oh my gosh all
the way home
the whole way the whole way and i i was
just just hooked and uh
so you know i got home and i said nat
i'm like hey
we we've been doing this doing that i'm
like we got a new goal you know we got a
new plan here and um
we talked you know we talked budget and
that was
was uh not the easiest thing to to
introduce but
um she she was i was up to my eyeballs
and babies and toddlers
i was not sure i wanted to take on a
whole nother challenge he was doing such
a good job with my finances i was like
just
let's just keep doing what we're doing
yeah but he wasn't gonna let it go
i just wanted to step it up a little bit
and um
anyway um ken coleman there he was the
emcee of the
of the uh rachel cruz les bless parrot
uh
marriage and money event that you guys
did in minneapolis a few years ago
natalie and i went to that and uh
natalie really connected with
with rachel's message about permission
to spend
um we've always we've lived a really
frugal life you know
like we've always had hand-me-down
clothes and we've shopped at goodwill
thrift stores stuff like that we've
always been pretty tight
but um when she was talking about
permission to spend and putting that in
the budget
i couldn't really wrap my head around
that and then as she talked it through i
was like okay
this is gonna make life easier um and so
i was like let's
let's try it let's go ahead and try it
because i won't
i won't you know stop when i see
something like when our kids need
clothes i won't be like
oh i don't know i don't know if i want
to spend that but the permission to
spend is a big big yeah it is
that's really what the budget is it's
because you decided together
that this meets our goals and we have
this much allocated to this
so you have to spend it on that because
that's what's that's what it's for yeah
that's awesome
yeah so was that a moment where the
budget thing was a little bit like i
don't know and then when she gave you
that psychology on that it was like
oh now the budget's not this big nasty
monster
very interesting yeah that's awesome
yeah i grew up working from a really
really young age and when we had our
first daughter we decided to stay
i was gonna stay home and take care of
the kids so not having an income
going into um things together
i was like i can't spend anything and i
felt terrible spending money that he was
bringing home so
that kind of gave it a purpose that it
wasn't his money it was our money
together
and that also really helped having that
budget put there yeah
wow way to go guys and your house is
paid for
at the end of the story touchdown yep
it's all about
downloading and binging a podcast pretty
much
and that it didn't stop there dave you
know i i just submerged myself in your
material from there on out
and um it was uh a big motivator to uh
you know stay focused and um keep uh
keep the task at hand yeah well way to
go you guys we're so proud of you
well done who are your biggest
cheerleaders oh my gosh we
we have such a good network of friends
at home our family
um they've all just been super
supportive and and
have really helped us along the way yeah
that's good
good well well done you guys so well
done
proud of you now that you're done you
don't have a payment in the world
what are you gonna do next you know
we're gonna
travel a little bit more good and we're
gonna be
um more giving you know we're gonna
we're gonna give back a little bit more
i think good
good that's a good answer well done good
job well we got a copy of the legacy
journey for you that is the
definitely where you are you're going to
bring the a whole new legacy into your
world because of what you've done and i
copy the total money makeover for you to
give away
pay it forward and get somebody else on
this journey with you uh give them the
encouragement of your story because you
got quite a testimony
very very well done and you brought the
kiddos with you what are their names and
ages let's get them up into the shot
all right so we got brad he's 14. we've
got maddie she's 10.
and macy's nine and elita is six all
right
good looking guys now they've all the
way from minneapolis if they've been
practicing
at that time a couple times yeah i think
we kind of know what we're doing i think
i think we'll pull it off all right good
deal good deal sam and natalie bradley
maddie macy and elita
320 000 paid off in 58 months making 115
to two and a quarter house and
everything
these are weird people count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i love it very well done you guys
very well done that's amazing it changes
everything
yeah really does you look at four kids
and you look at the legacy they've been
handed they're not even 40 years old
no and they haven't paid for 500 000
house
game changer wow it changes everything
i mean if you just take a house payment
from 40 years old
and invest a house payment from 40 to
65.
that's going to be millions upon
millions of dollars that one thing
yeah just that one thing yeah your most
powerful wealth building tool
is your income yeah and when you don't
give it
to countrywide when you don't give it to
toyota motor credit ford motor credit
when you don't give it to
master card who named that anyway
when you don't give it to discovered
bondage
when you don't give it to american
distress
when you have your most powerful wealth
building tool and you invest it
from 40 to 65 it's millions
of dollars everyone in america should be
a millionaire
instead we build tall buildings in the
skyline for major corporations that are
screwing you
yeah it's time to stop it
they stopped it they're free they broke
the chains off
you see superman rip the chains off oh
yeah they just busted them off yeah no
more kryptonite in that house
no pretty cool stuff dude
yeah i love it i love what she said
about rachel's talk one line
in there changed the entire attitude
towards the discipline it wasn't holding
us the budget wasn't holding us down it
was freeing us
up fantastic oh it's a
decision it's amazing yeah i mean
permission to spend
yeah that's why people love rachel
because she's so nice and
yeah she says are way nicer than you
dave i know and i'm just so you're like
do a budget or you're an idiot she goes
hey guys don't stop it hey guys it's
permission to spin
and it works it works so good
stop it
[Laughter]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host
today earl is in kansas city hey earl
how are you
i'm doing well thank you very much my
situation
is very simply this i'm a minister i've
been
in a non-profit ministry now for eight
years
and for the last seven years i've been
running a program
uh to help men get off their feet uh if
they're
have mental disorders we help them get
med compliant to
go on with their life if they have
addictions we help them get clean
i teach about 20 different classes
after my program which is six weeks they
go on to a nine month long program to
really help them get stable
the reason why i'm calling is
about six months ago they hired a new
chief operating officer
to run ministries and
she's coming in and making all so many
changes
that i'm really sort of going to be on
the sideline now
and that's okay if it makes the ministry
better i'm
all for that 100 however
a week ago i sent an email and i said
hey can you tell me exactly what my
job's going to be because i'm not
certain
in writing can you tell me what i'm
going to be doing they have not
responded yet
and i'm just feeling you know i've
ministered to over a thousand men in
this time
and i've built this ministry so much
and now the person's coming in and i'm
not mad at them
i don't have sex or grapes i just
i want to be used of god now i have so
many talents that aren't being used
right now
i have thought about doing something
else i just don't know what to do
and still remain in god's will and still
be a servant
of the lord to use the gifts that i have
well earl first of all let's acknowledge
the fact that you may not have sour
grapes you may not be mad but you're
hurt
and you need to acknowledge that and and
that just is a painful situation
while i don't know the details does it
sound like you do either the fact that
you
emailed i think that's a great step hey
what does a win look like for me that's
essentially what you asked in a very
uh clear email and there's been no
response in over a week so that's not
healthy
and even in ministries there's poor
leadership uh poor leadership exists
everywhere because we live in a
imperfect world but i want to address
the big thing that you're feeling is
that you don't know what to do to remain
in in the call and that's just simply
not true you don't know the details yet
and and because you haven't even
decided hey am i supposed to leave i
think probably that's coming
in your future i think you need to be
exploring that um
but you're going to continue to do the
same type of work
whether specifically exactly like what
you've been doing
don't overthink that but the fact is
until you feel a release from ministry
you're still supposed to be in ministry
and there's so many ways that you can do
that whether that be
in a non-profit uh or a para church
ministry like you've been in or
in the church itself but i don't want
you to be so discouraged that hey i've
poured so much of myself
into this ministry last seven eight
years i don't know what i'll do next
you don't know the details but you but
you do know you're still going to serve
people
do you understand what i'm saying and
you do know you're going to do something
similar to what you used to do
that was where you were you were you
were in a zone that's exactly right
yeah well i i can't i can't it may not
be there but you do
none of what you've done in the past is
lost that's right
oh no no question uh i'm not talking
about the people you served i'm talking
about it's not lost in the
it's became experience in your brain
you're better at what you do now
than you were 10 years ago agreed well
yes i i appreciate that i i if i go for
a week without preaching or teaching i'm
like
i can't wait okay so earl right there
right there's the answer yeah you need
to be preaching and teaching
don't make it any more complicated than
that so now it's not what i'm doing it's
where i'm going to do it
hey god it feels like this door is
closing
so open up a door show me i mean you
know this man
the bible says without faith it is what
impossible to please yeah so at this
moment you're hurting and i understand
that i would i would maybe ask for one
more clarification
if i get another delay of three or four
days uh brother i wouldn't read into
that that that is a sign
and it's time to move on and i'd be
looking but you know exactly what you
need to be doing it's now where can i
preach
where can i teach where can i pour into
men
the least of these and that's what
you've been doing so uh you're in the
kansas city missouri area
there's a lot of ministries whether it
be again in the local church or the pear
church ministry
even outside of kansas city yeah this is
a function of you saying god
uh i understand this door is closing i'm
gonna continue to do the same type of
thing but now in a different place
earl yes i thought you went off the air
so no
don't worry i thought you cut me off
that's good that's fantastic that's
going to work i also have
i'm a gifted writer i'm a gifted
musician i've got so much to offer
yeah the answer is so you you need to
change your narrative it's not that you
don't know
what you're going to what you're going
to do you don't know where you're going
to do it
that's just part of this deal yeah good
job earl yeah you got this
that stinks dave because you know
there's poor leadership in ministry as
well
it's just bad yeah because listen if
they
don't have a seat for him tell him
because of the changes
it is unkind yes to be unclear
ignore the guy gently serving kind
yes guy yeah and all you got to do is
look at him and tell him the truth yeah
that's the only kind of thing you can do
whatever the truth is yes we've got a
big deal we're cooking up for you over
here
or you're we got a big deal we're
cooking you out of here
whatever it is tell him yeah that's all
you got to do it's you just these
it's it's cowardice 100
couldn't add leadership cowardice
they're going to ignore this guy's email
for a week because they don't know how
to tell him
that maybe he's not in the big picture
anymore
and it kills a guy like that man when i
first started leading
bossing people i in the name
of being nice i was i i wouldn't tell
people the truth
i know it's hard to imagine but i
you know i would just beat around the
bush or i would just delay or i'm just
i don't want to say something that's
gonna that's a i don't want to have a
hard conversation with somebody
and i thought that was being nice and i
finally realized to be unkind as to be
or to be unclear is to be unkind
one of the greatest leadership lessons
you can ever learn that little phrase
right there
to be unclear is to be unkind you it
requires courage
and strength to be kind
and sit and look at someone and say
you've served this place a long time
a thousand men we're taking a left turn
here a right turn here
and we don't have a seat for you when
the music stops and we want to honor you
and honor the work that you've done and
help you on to your next thing
yeah and that that should have been the
response
five minutes after that email sent
because this ministry that this lady's
running
is not that big no he's down the hall
right oh she walked past him seven times
oh yeah it's just cowardice
just cowardice yep that's right jessica
is
uh questionable whether we're gonna get
to you or not go real fast jessica
um hi i live in tallahassee and
i bought a house a couple of years ago
and i'm buying it from the owner so i
don't have
a mortgage or anything as far as like
interest involved
but i need to put a roof on my house and
i'm just starting on baby step one
and i'm trying to find out like should i
continue
with my baby step one and just continue
to build the
it up until i have enough yeah you need
a thousand dollars before you need a
roof
is the roof leaking okay it
does i mean i have tarps on it but it's
like after about three or four months
and the sun bleaches the tarps out and
then i have to replace them again
and that's like 250 300 what's it take
to put a roof on the house um
i've been quoted five grand and they
want to help me out because i'm a single
mom
um so i'm really hoping to go with that
company but that quote was
pre it was 2019 when i got it
yeah you need to get some more quotes
this house is not that big
no it's not very big at all yeah what do
you make honey
um i usually um less than 30
28. yeah five grams a lot of money in
your world
yeah um are you in a good church if
you're not in a good church get in one
or find a local pastor and tell him your
story
and ask him if there's some guys in the
church that can help you out yes
this is an opportunity for somebody to
help and you need some help right now
blue tarps ain't cutting it i don't
blame you i'm sorry
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
theramsi show.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host ken coleman ramsey
personality host of the ken
coleman show where he talks about jobs
and careers
and finding work that you love
finding work that matters he's my
co-host today that means you could talk
about your career as well as anything
else you want to call in about the phone
number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five
christina is with us in phoenix arizona
hi christina how are you
i'm good thank you how are you better
than i deserve what's up
thanks for taking my call um i was
wondering
about selling our home in this great
market right now
um so we purchased the home uh for about
160 we owe
about 110 still um and
it's listing for about 450.
the thing is that we have significant
student loans
um we have about 275 worth of student
loans 275 000
um for what who's the doctor or lawyer
my husband is a physician's assistant
and i'm a mental health therapist
good okay so your household income over
200
um it should be this year um this year i
really hit it hard with my own
my own private practice good good and
what was it last year
um about 165 yeah
okay and so you got a pretty good
trajectory on both of your careers
which is the payoff for getting good
degrees but now we've got the uh the
debt associated with them right
yeah yeah well it sounds like you've got
a choice
mathematically you've got a choice live
like a college student
spend absolutely no money and keep your
house
and be debt-free in three years
or sell your house
my husband wants to keep it for like a
rental type of no
you don't need a rental you're broke
you're 275 000 in debt you're not in a
position to be investing in real estate
well not right now i know we pay
everything off i know okay
okay so do you want to live there with
absolutely no lifestyle
work like absolute maniacs and clean up
this
ridiculous mess that you have in three
years
or less or do you want to sell the house
to get out now
either one is okay there's no bad answer
here
it's what you want to do
i would love to sell i'm i'm eager to
get out of debt
um he likes the idea or he's playing
around with the idea of selling it
but um he's definitely more for the
he wants it for that potential passive
type of income later on
no um well that's that's long-term
thinking which is not bad
but i don't know if he realizes what
this is about to cost him he's not going
out to eat for the next three years
he's not going on vacation for the next
three years two kiddos
yeah it's hard yeah um
kiddos survive without restaurants they
have done it for centuries yeah they
don't even care
give them a bowl of of goldfish and
chicken nuggets and they're thrilled so
this isn't about the kids
i think dave brings up a good point does
he understand no
how hard this is going to be to pay this
off in three years i don't think he does
well no i mean he's yeah he's really
good with money so he's
attacking no he's not he's 275 000 in
debt he's not good with money
i mean he attacked it really hard during
this uh no interest i mean he went down
from
170 to about 140 so
he's he's definitely working hard at
that
i i just think that if you're the one
that wants to pay the house off now
you've got to cast a little bit more
vision for him
that's the one i would choose but i
would sit down with stacy and go here's
why i want this
if we sell this now boom it's done we
both make really good income
we can rent in a really nice place and
still
be emergency fund fully funded
immediately with the kind of income you
guys have
and we could save up and then we can get
a nicer house and put a really great
down payment on it
i just think you got to show him the
other side of this as opposed to what i
think is a status symbol which is this
i'd like to have passive income with
this small house
i would just cast different vision here
have you guys really talked about
your side of this thing and where it
fast forwards your life
so much faster
have you done that i have yes i have
honed in on that like this week that's
why
you know i've been trying to call all
week no i'm saying
you've talked about that and painted a
clear vision for how this fast forwards
everything
i i believe i have yes okay so here
here's what
i heard i just told you to pay off a
hundred thousand dollars a year and you
went and bragged about him paying off 30
000 in one year
well in a couple months oh a couple
months he did that
you said during the no interest and the
no interest has been a year
so that's why i'm sorry um oh yeah i
mean it's probably since
i guess about a year or since the
beginning of the year or so
the beginning of the year you've hit it
hard yeah you've hit it hard
okay because a hundred thousand dollars
a year is eight thousand dollars a month
so thirty thousand would be done in just
a little over three months
if he did that then he's hitting it hard
i'll go with you okay
but i heard it i heard a year i thought
i heard a year when you said that you
didn't say a year but i heard
since they stopped having interest on
the loans which has been a year so
anyway
okay so yeah and by the way he was
paying off his debt
not our debt so somehow i don't know
where we got on that but i think the two
of you need to sit down together
and go all right one of these two things
is going to happen we're either going to
have no lifestyle
and we're going to hit this hard for
three years and be debt-free
300 000 in three years or we're going to
sell the house
rent for a little while have an
emergency fund build up
cash for a down payment and buy another
house and we'll buy rentals later
you're always going to have good incomes
because you have two very good career
fields if you work hard and
you know continue with your craft and so
on right so
you know a 200 250 000 income it's not
hard to save up and
pay off your own home and then save up
and buy your first rental
within the first decade here it's very
doable but
but but i think you're getting the cart
in front of the horse he is he's
starting we're talking about rental
properties
while we still have a house mortgage and
we still have 275 000
of student loan debt it's out of order
that comes
later so i i would either sell the house
or hold on to it with the idea that
we're probably going to sell it
later and move up in-house and get that
house paid off before we start adding
rentals
paying it off and paying off the student
loan debt and then going and taking a
mortgage to buy your next home
is not something i would tell you to do
and so he's
again putting the cart before the horse
with all that so
i'm kicking this rental thing down the
road a little bit i like rental property
i want you to have some rental property
but you don't broke people shouldn't buy
rental property
it's not a good thing makes you broker
that's why i call them real estate
brokers
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five ken coleman
is my co-host today this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225 chris is with us in fort smith
arkansas hi chris how are you
good thank you dave thank you ken so
much so i have a new situation
my grandmother just recently passed away
and i am set to receive around fifty
thousand dollars
um due to a lack of me caring about my
grades in high school
i had to take out a lot of student loans
and i worked really really hard
graduate top of my class during college
and now i have a really
great job with the federal government um
i currently owe 71 000
145 federal loans and then forty six
thousand
two hundred and sixty five dollars with
uh sally may
um i currently pay nine hundred dollars
a month in sally may
uh but fortunately my employer will pay
off all of my federal loans um
uh and they're currently paying 678 per
month
uh so my question if i say for eight
more years
they will pay my federal loans off
completely so my question is
is um you know with this inheritance
money i'm planning on paying off my
silent completely but then after that
should i use that payment of 900 a month
uh and just add that on to uh the amount
that's
already being paid by my employer and
just knock out my federal loans
uh quicker or should i use the 900 a
month
um and invest it uh even though that
will um
you know i know that we shouldn't invest
until after we get out baby step two
yeah and so how much is the loan that
will be paid off over eight years again
uh it's 71 145
okay and they're paying a hundred
percent of it but over eight years yes
sir
yes sir okay what do you make
uh forty thousand dollars a month i'm
not in my bringing here i'm sorry
it's a government job everybody wanted
for a minute there okay
all right so is this a good career path
for you or is this golden handcuffs
um it is uh you know it's it's
um my degree is uh
in an emergency management and so it's
kind of in public service and that's
what i wanted it to be
um so i you know really it is long term
um so there is there is a path here for
you to make more than 40 000 then
oh yes sir absolutely okay because you
need to make more than 40 000.
yes sir i definitely recognize that you
know i need to have a bigger shovel and
you know plan on doing some some side
jobs as well with that all said then
what i tell folks to do where you've got
a
uh someone else that's willing to pay
off your loans and i'm not talking about
government forgiveness this is an actual
employer program where they're reducing
and paying your debt off
okay so what i would do is i want you to
save your emergency once you're debt
free not counting the 71 000
then i want you to save 71 000
okay and that's your next goal as if you
had to pay
off the debt but we're not going to pay
it off we're going to put it in savings
okay okay now once you've done that then
you've got that and you could make that
your emergency fund if you want i don't
care but i need at least 71
000 in there before you move on to baby
step four and here's my plan
if uh you get in a situation where
some bizarre thing happens and there's
like an ethics
situation i'll use that okay something
like that where you just
you cannot stay you have got to leave
because they're doing illegal stuff or
something like that right i mean you're
you know you can see no reason to leave
right now but i'm saying something
happens that's bizarre
and blows up this job you've got the
money in the savings account to write a
check and be debt-free and you're not
forced to stay there with these golden
handcuffs of this debt reduction pro
benefit yes sir
so you've got an exit strategy so in
other words if you've got 71 000
in debt that they're gonna pay off and
you've got the same 71 000 in a savings
account that you're not going to touch
for any reason
so you can hit eject if you need to uh
then we're going to call you debt free
does that make sense yes sir it does and
then let them pay it off and you're
going to have the 71 000 left over
if everything works out the way you
think it's going to uh and then move on
and start putting 15
of your income into retirement from
there
that's a lot and that's very unusual by
the way
i i bet i haven't heard of a program
that does that
10 times ever in 30 years
so that's a very it's an unusually good
benefit um but
but we can't close our eyes and act like
the debt is not still there
it's what we would call in finance a
contingent liability
it's as if you co-signed on 71 000
and you were hoping the person who was
the primary signer actually paid the
freaking bill
but if they don't you owned a hook
and that's the case here it's almost as
if you're the co-signer now
they're they're the primary on the bill
but if they don't pay it for whatever
reason
you're on the hook so we're going to
have that money as cover that contingent
liability
it's not technically a contingent
liability but that's the way we'll treat
it
for purposes of execution on this
process our question today comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings
free samples free shipping and new
promos all the time
they are an incredible company if you
want window blinds i'm getting ready to
order some
by the way and i have used this company
a bunch of times they are incredible use
the promo code ramsey
to get the best possible deal
today's question comes from sj in
wisconsin he writes
i'm a licensed architect and i've been
in the industry for 10 years while i
make a good living
for years now i felt the pull to use my
expertise as a ministry opportunity
i have completed one pro bono project
with a ministry partner
and now we've started another pro bono
project i feel god is calling me to do
this full time
i don't know how to help those who have
no way to pay while taking care of my
own family
how can i blend my need to earn a living
with my calling well i love this
question
uh and i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
question someone saying
well i feel god is calling me to do this
full time however
when you feel that pull sj that god's
calling you to do this
full time or maybe more i don't believe
god's going to call you into something
and you not be able to take care of your
family so that's my
uh theological system it's inconsistent
with god so he's going to provide
so here's what i would tell you you're
not going to make this step you're not
going to step out of being an architect
into the great unknown and then say hey
god uh
fill this i think god will open up a
door if you ask
and scripture is very clear on that so
you can look into okay
what would it look like for me to do
this from a ministry standpoint and i
think
potentially the answer is in your
question if you have as an architect
work with a ministry partner that's a
ministry organization
to uh be able to do this type of work
for families
then you need to fight figure out if
they're willing to bring you on full
time
and you kind of spearhead some of these
projects whether that be a habitat for
humanity and that's just an example
or whoever these ministries are however
dave you and i have talked about this
and one thing i would push back if you
were on the phone with me i want to know
more
because ministry is not separate from
your occupation
genesis chapter 2 makes it very clear
that we were created to work and when we
work we use the talents that god gave us
he's the creator
and we do work good work is a ministry
and it's not inseparable
if you don't separate the two you need
to start looking at your paying
customers
it's right as spiritually valuable as
your non-paying customers
that's right and could god be calling
you to do more of this
but who says he's calling you away from
your architectural career
you and i have a good friend who's a
bone and joint doctor who's working on
your foot
right now that's right as we speak
that's right and
you're going to pay him oh yeah for that
when you see him he prays for you every
time he does he's a wonderful friend and
a good man
and but every one of the people he
ministers to
pays him well i don't know he may work
for free sometimes
i wouldn't say that i don't know i don't
i don't know that but it is his
profession
his profession is his ministry and
allows him to do more
and he gets paid yes quite and there's
nothing inconsistent with that
no so there's the problem is you've
identified the wrong things as holy
uh-huh non-profit is not the only holy
thing
nonprofit is a an accounting entry
nonprofit is an irs designation
it's not in the bible nonprofit is not
more holy
yeah than a doc working on you and
getting paid that's right praying for
you
for god to heal your leg and that's his
expertise totally heal your leg
and be careful not to feel the heart
pull to do
more ministry as a call or director from
god to leave your
income in your full-time profession he
might be
but don't assume that that's the case
that's what i want to be careful of yeah
you can do more
being gentler than i would be yeah of
course yeah of course
everyone is yeah i don't think that's
god
yeah i would question it
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five tyson and natalie are with
us in ogden utah and it says on my
screen
you guys are debt free congratulations
thanks dude we called to tell you thank
you so much for all the good things
you're doing and for helping us get here
well i'm so proud of you guys well done
how much have you paid off
155 000 wow how long did that take
about 13 years cool and your range of
income during that time
uh we started about 42 000
we're at about 75 and we've gone up and
down a little bit in between
okay what do you guys do for a living i
i manufacture nutritional products okay
and i'm home with the kids and uh teach
an accounting course part-time online
cool
so what kind of debt was the 155 000
it was a house oh talking to weird
people
how old are you guys i just celebrated
my 43rd birthday my wife celebrated 42nd
wow wow and you're 100 debt free
yep wow what do you what's the house
worth
well now it's about well in the market
we're at over here about 350.
oh that's so nice
so tell us your story what happened
well i'm allergic to debt and we
we just started paying down the house
and we took your class in
2010 just for fun because that's what i
like to do for fun
i love accounting family finance that's
what i studied so
um we we took your class and we just
kept paying and we just paid every month
and paid extra when we could
and it was just really simple nothing
flashy and
here we are wow good for you guys
well you plowed right through in 13
years
man that's perseverance
yes were you systematically paying extra
on it all the time or just hit or miss
um we set a goal to to get certain
amounts we could and we then we
refinanced to a shorter term loan
we kept paying the same amount that we
already were doing so that helped us a
lot
yeah so we started on a 30-year loan
when we started in
06 the interest rates were really high
so they were like 6.75 so we really did
pay it like
a 15 for a year and a half until it went
up in enough value that we were able to
get rid of pmi and it was exactly what a
15 year was and then
we paid it off early from there wow
look at you guys very so very systematic
very uh very much process i love it
that's a that is a beautiful story
that's a real testament to your personal
discipline
yeah i wanted to ask you how did you
mentally
handle the dips when you had you had the
income changes and then you had
different things that had happened i
mean this is 13 years this is a long
time
and you just stayed with it what would
you say to folks who are in that mindset
of hey i want to pay the house off is it
possible
well when we had the increase in income
we went up to as high as 89 000 and we
didn't increase our living we just
threw it in the roth around the house
and then when we had the dip
in income we went through unemployment
and we went to zero we just
hung on and we were prepared and we just
weathered the storm and so
to other people that are out there i
would just say you know we're real
average and anybody can do this
so you just um when it gets hard
you just um you dig
deep and you celebrate the little
successes i love that they weathered the
storm dave they didn't quit
yeah the storms come right yeah so all
you have to do is be ready for them
don't be shocked they're coming yeah
that's a way to go you guys
very very proud of you guys so uh you
took the class for
fun in 2010 and here you are in 2021
with a paid for house
yeah wow so you were already on your way
by then
look at you this is so fun how does it
feel to not have a payment
in the world it's great
a little strange but we we like it it's
almost surreal
so how many kids do you have and what
are their names and ages
we have four and there is
jacqueline is oldest and she is 15
then wesley is our next oldest and he's
12.
then we have tommy who's 11 and chloe
who's 9.
all right are they around or is it going
to be a family affair to do your debt
free scream or what three out of the
four
with us that's pretty good that's not
bad good good well we've got a copy of
the legacy journey for you
uh that's for sure your next chapter in
this story and an extra copy of the
total money makeover for you to be able
to give
away to someone and start their journey
so proud of you guys you're absolute
heroes
well done well done we appreciate you so
much
we appreciate you tyson and natalie
ogden
utah 155 000 paid off in 13 years
making 42-75 count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one
[Applause]
oh man that's so fun
very very well done you guys
you know oftentimes when we see these
things we talk about
the legacy and changing your family tree
and we've developed all these teaching
tools for you to teach your kids
how to handle money and that completes
the
changing of the family tree that way so
right now we've got them on sale we've
just dropped our prices up to
80 on our best-selling kids products so
you can have fun
and you can have an educational summer
all at the same time the adventure pack
is a family favorite that includes
the new story time collection all of the
juniors adventures are in
one big thick book now financial peace
junior
the smart saver bank all for
teaching kids how to have money how to
do
well with money and the best part is you
can add an extra kid for each sibling
all of this is 80 off right now
got a teenager well the teen
entrepreneur toolbox by anthony o'neil
is the perfect safe and flexible way for
them to create their own summer job
turn a hobby or an idea into a real
business
you can learn hard work you can learn
leadership you can learn responsibility
you learn how to make a profit it's a
good thing it's a good thing that's how
this country was built
so all of this eighty percent off right
now kids and teens
sale at the online store at
ramseysolutions.com ramseysolutions.com
terrell
is in sacramento hi terrell how are you
hello dave i'm well how about yourself
great how can we help
yes so um
my question is i have a paid off car
it's one year old and i got it appraised
for
just about 26 000
now that car was my only and last
debt my question is should i sell the
car
because that's that's essentially all of
my net worth
but should i sell the car and the reason
for my question is
it has a maintenance package for five
more years
what's your income well
full disclosure i'm a student and a
veteran so
i've got a little bit of disability
income as well as working full-time
so just about might say 50 000.
okay well if you like the car you can
keep it it's less than half your annual
income
and it's paid for so okay yeah
that's fine um it's you're right it is
your entire net worth
and you don't want you know more than 50
of your income tied up in things with
wheels and motors
and you're right close to that but
you're not
and you know but but here's the trick
going forward if you really want to
become wealthy you keep the smallest
possible percentage of your income
tied up in things that are going down in
value
and so you wouldn't make this mistake
again
it's not such a big mistake you've got
to undo it and sell it but it's a lot of
car
for you it's over the top really
but i'd probably keep it if i'm in your
shoes and thanks for your service to our
country sir
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today isaiah 26 3 you will
keep in perfect peace those whose minds
are steadfast
because they trust in you blueholt said
it is not the load that breaks you down
it's the way you carry it
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225 jason is
with us in fort worth hi jason how are
you
how's it going guys better than we
deserve what's up
got a question for you so i kind of want
to make sure i'm
i'm on the right track i'm looking to
buy a business or buy a portion
of a business and i'm just kind of want
to make sure i'm in the right stage of
my life and i got
things in order where i can do that okay
um so how much is it going to be
so i've got an agreement with the guy
for 33
of the company and it'd be about 40
thousand dollars why would you buy 32
percent
or 33 so i am kind of in a portion where
i came in as a business developer
so he wants to be part of the company
and it's a side gig i have
so i'm not going to be there full time
but i can be there for
i can have 33 company and still do my
primary job
no thank you i'll pass yeah absolutely
hard pass
you wanna know why you could yes i would
you have absolutely no power
you have a minority position and he can
decide to
make decisions tomorrow that bankrupted
and you're 33
equals zero you have absolutely no say
whatsoever in this
you're a minority stockholder in a small
business
that's broke by the way because they
need they need a cash influx
now would it be better if i went if i
could work out fifty percent
fifty-one fifty-one percent yeah then
you can control it
i'd prefer a hundred though i mean if 40
buys 33 120 000 buys the whole stinking
thing
if you gain money well the part of the
thing is that
i've i've doubled the income of the
business for
about i do think he's under buying the
company as well
if he'll sell it for 120 000 do you have
the money
no i do not okay so do you have the 40
yes i do okay how much do you have to
put towards this business
i've got about 80. okay and what is the
net profits of the business
so as of right now it is a subcontractor
for
for construction so it kind of
fluctuates but right now it's about
100 uh 200 000
profit yes profit
after everyone is paid and all expenses
are paid
yes
i'm so confused why he would sell this
for a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars so he doesn't want to sell he
just wants to sell at 33
because and part of it is because i've
i have the context i work for a general
contractor so i have the context to grow
the business
exponentially and that that's where my
33
would come in yeah okay
so what this is is a bad comp plan
he wants to compensate you for all the
value you've brought to the business
and the way he's doing that is he's
putting you in as a minority shareholder
and it's a good way for you to end up
with with losing money rather than
making money you shouldn't have to pay
for this
so what he should do is agree to pay you
a percentage of the profits
as your comp okay
pay you like a partner pay you like a
partner without any stock transfer at
all okay but you don't have ownership
you just are paid off the bottom line
like a partner
that's how that's how our operating
board is paid here at ramsey
i've got 17 operating board members all
of them are paid off the same line
i'm paid off of but they don't own stock
it might be for risk reasons
no it's that it's because they make a
whole lot of money that way and i want
you to make a whole lot of money
but i don't want you to put in any money
and i don't want you to
feel like you own something when you
don't because when you own 33
of something you own nothing this is a
side hustle for you
how much are you making personally off
of this side hustle
i'm making 40 000 up the side hustle and
me and my life together make about 155.
yeah ask him to pay you one-fourth of
the profit
yep for doing the work you do because
you're bringing all the growth
and that's that's gonna that would be
fifty thousand a year that'd be
give you a ten thousand dollar a year
raise and then as you bring in more and
more and more
he keeps paying you a fourth of the
profits you're gonna make a lot of money
as you make more
profit yeah so but you're what you're
con what he's confusing and you're
confusing is a comp plan
with a partnership and you do not need
you don't want to pay to own
a 33 interest now if he wants to give
you
a third of the company to say thank you
for growing the business
sure i'll take it
but i'm not paying for it because you
have zero voting rights
he anything you say he can say i don't
wanna do it
i'm gonna do this instead and he could
just change his mind or his wife could
come in and decide
that she wants everybody to be fired and
he fires everybody
i mean all kinds of crazy but hap stuff
happens with people when they do not own
the control of a company that they have
paid to
have a percentage of yeah and so it's
just a problem
i i would not pay for it but maybe he
could just give it to you
if you've grown the business that much
yeah it sounds like
that this guy wants him to keep making
it rain and he realizes that
that jason is the rainmaker well here's
the challenge with that
if you're the rainmaker at some point
you know he's got to give you more of
that
or else you could go do this on your own
you've got all the context this is
subcontracting
this is all about relationships that
subcontracting and construction
that's all that is listen it can be a
comp plan yes without it being an
ownership plan that's right because you
actually see
the money you you've watched me do this
around here you've been around here yeah
15 years
you know you've watched me there's
rainmakers in this place yeah and you
know what
they make a lot of money right because
they make us a lot of money
and it's fair it's fair to uh share with
them
but you know how much ramsey stock they
own zero zero
so i don't i didn't get confused between
ownership and comp
and compensation does not have to be
stock yeah and to your point dave
they don't want ownership if they're
making rain they're making it
they're making it they know this is not
about ownership and so i don't even know
i don't know if this guy's trying to
pull a deal here no
he just doesn't understand i think he
just get confused he thinks he's doing a
nice thing
yeah and it's not it's it's a 40 000
i think that's right yeah yeah yeah so
ask him just give you the 33
or just say you know what i don't need
33 25 would be great just give me a
fourth yeah
and then let him pay you off the bottom
line and then pay you 40 pay your salary
too
then you'll be getting some serious
money going yes that'd be there you go
ding ding and that's the win-win help
him see that it is a win-win he may not
even know how to articulate win-win
which is what we suspect here so so
really go back with what dave laid out
here this is going to be a fabulous deal
but he if he decides to spend 250
000 on a computer system or a software
program or purchase a truck
that's correct you got zero say in that
uh-huh
zero yep if you're the if you're a
minority owner and you paid forty
thousand dollars to sit there and get
additional comp yeah you're kind of like
buying con you're buying compensation is
what you're trying to do
and it's just not a plan it's not the
way to play it out so
uh we spend a lot of time on
compensation programs here and those of
you running businesses check out entree
leadership
uh we're really really good at it we
have figured out people do what you pay
them to do
and so we try to figure out all kinds of
interesting ways to pay people
to remind them that what they're doing
is what they get paid for
and it it's motivating as crud when you
get it right
and it's demotivating as crud when you
don't so
yeah and you know we made the decision a
long time ago that
this is not a publicly traded company uh
this is a
uh an organization operated uh
god owns it and the ramsay's run it and
then
and we're sharing yeah and we're very
very generous in our comp yeah
uh especially with rainmakers yeah you
know why because we want them to make
more rain
yeah why is this a hard formula for
corporate america they try to screw
everybody
you don't need to get screwed why why do
people do this you don't need to do it
so yeah it's good
very good it's a good question yeah an
interesting discussion thanks for
giving a soapbox for us to jump up on
can coleman good show today thank you
sir
james childs our producer kelly daniel
our associate producer and phone
screener great
job as always i am dave ramsey your host
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there is
ultimately only one way to financial
peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you